hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm gonna tell you how
you can live rent free
that's right you don't pay any rent and
live
in central london if you enjoy my videos
i'm giving top tips and hacks
every single day so please just do me a
very small favor
and smash the like button do that right
now and then i'm gonna tell you exactly
how you can live rent free in london so
let me explain
something that is known as house hacking
you've probably heard about hacking
people's banks
well maybe you haven't or hacking
computers maybe you have
well i'm gonna tell you how to hack into
houses now i'm not talking about doing
anything illegal
i'm not talking about doing anything
immoral or unethical some people try and
squat in houses they find empty houses
and then they just
move in there and they squat in the
house and sometimes if you stay there
for a certain amount of time as a
squatter you actually have squatters
rights which is just
scary i am not talking about that that
is immoral
i am talking about house hacking here's
what you want to do listen
just hear me to rent somewhere in london
even if you want to rent a shed right in
north central london how much are you
talking
we all know that it's like a thousand
pounds just to have a roof over your
head in london
even in just a room if you rent a room
it's gonna cost you like a grand
maybe fifteen hundred if it's in a
decent part of london would you agree
right okay good bet hold that thought if
it costs
a grand to 1500 just to have a roof over
your head and to rent a room
in london how much does it cost to rent
a two bed flat in london maybe two grand
what about a three bed is it three grand
no it's probably two and a half grand
they don't
they don't it's not a thousand pounds or
fifteen hundred pounds
per room that's not how it works so how
do you live rent free
you find a flat or an apartment
like this one this is a
three bed flat in central london now
listen i've not done loads of due
diligence on this there's loads
if you go on open rent there's loads of
three bed flats this one's in
sw1p this is literally
central central london right on the
river thames
so how much is this flat it's a
three bed flat and it's on the market
for two thousand
four hundred and fifty pounds there's
loads like this so if it's a three bed
flat
you've got a lounge you've got a kitchen
and you've got three beds
and it's on the market for 2450
couldn't you just agree to move in there
agree to pay the landlord 2450
but on the condition that you can have
lodges in the rooms
now the landlord doesn't care as long as
he's getting his rent
so then you move in and on the day you
move in
prior to moving in you advertise on
spare room
code uk two rooms in central
london right near the river thames you
rent each room out
for 1250 pounds we already agreed that
you couldn't rent a room for less than a
grand
so you rent out that room for 12.50 that
room for 12.50
you live in your own room and you live
rent free because the 1250s that they
pay you
you pass that on to the landlord and you
live paying
zero rent in central london that
is house hacking if i had to start all
again
from scratch tomorrow and i had nothing
if i lost my family i lost my money
i lost everything guess what i wouldn't
be paying any rent i'd be moving
straight in
to a house share where i pay the
landlord direct
and then i move people into the i mean
i've known people that have done this
with a four bed flat they're getting
paid to live in london
you don't have to do it in london you
can do liverpool do you realize you can
rent a room in liverpool for like 400
pounds you can rent a whole house for
400 pounds so if you live in liverpool
rent a house for 400 pounds and rent out
two of the spare rooms
for 400 pounds each boom shaka you're
getting paid
just to live this is house hacking if
you are gonna do this
go and do it but tell me that you did it
okay i wanna i wanna have some
significance from doing this video
so hit the like subscribe for more tips
like this you can subscribe up here
and if you do this hit me up on
instagram or social media
and tell me that you are living
rent-free so i can get a little bit of
satisfaction
from making this video thanks so much
i'll see you next time